so we spoke earlier uh trump's second
impeachment trial is over he's been
acquitted exactly as we predicted
i was expecting five republicans to vote
guilty we got seven
that's something but still not the 67
that we're required to convict
now with impeachment out of the way and
not that this should have delayed covid
relief anyway but now with impeachment
out of the way
no more excuses it's time to get covered
relief done now
i am already to be very clear i think
joe biden's
been doing a good job so far i like how
much he's gotten done and how quickly
he's got it done
joe biden did say checks going out right
away
when i'm sworn in if we have the two
senate seats democrats have the two
senate seats
we're getting close to a month and we're
still dealing with
how exactly is this uh stimulus bill
going to pass
it is increasingly and abundantly clear
that at least
in the lead up republicans aren't going
to play ball now i've said before
i think that the political risk of
voting no
on the stimulus bill is too great for
all republicans to vote no i believe
that if democrats
move forward with passing the covet
stimulus package 1.9 trillion dollars
via budget reconciliation which requires
only a simple majority meaning they can
do it with
50 senators and kamala harris's
tie-breaking boat vote
i believe that if that's the way to do
it they should do it this is too
important and it was joe biden's promise
after
all but i think you will get some
republicans who go
who go for it because many of the same
republicans
who voted guilty for trump in the second
impeachment trial
have more moderate constituencies and or
don't care so much about being seen as
sticking with the republicans and being
on the team
i think it's quite plausible mitt romney
would go for it susan collins
lisa murkowski ben sasse pat toomey a
lot of the same people who voted guilty
on saturday for donald trump
i think ultimately will come around
because they realize that this is
actually what their constituents want
so there's a new new york times article
which says
the biden agenda now with now with
impeachment out of the way the biden
agenda takes center stage
and that the order the priorities will
be passing the 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill
and then doing green infrastructure and
then doing immigration and then doing
climate change and and starting to go
through this list now
that's probably 18 months of stuff we
have to be realistic about how quickly
paul you know maybe a year it's not
clear
but we just have to get the covid relief
bill done
it's very clear that that is the next
step it's very clear that joe biden is
now risking
failing on a major campaign promise you
can you can argue that he already failed
in the sense that
he said it would happen right away and
it's been a month he initially said it'd
be two thousand dollar checks then it
was well it'll be fourteen hundred to
get to the total of two thousand
okay some are defending that some are
not some are saying
it's a flip-flop regardless we're almost
a month and it's time to do it and so
the report from the new york times says
that this is now the priority
and that joe biden and democrats are
willing to go it alone
what has changed over the last two weeks
nothing joe biden
brought republicans to the white house
they wanted a plan
that was it was humiliatingly small it
was a micro plan
i would call it and it was less than one
third the size of what joe biden and
democrats want
you're negotiating with people who are
negotiating in bad faith they're
negotiating to down
down to something that's pathetic it's
peanuts for what we need
just do it it's time to get it done and
uh we will we will soon see
uh whether joe biden understands the
limits of so-called unity in the limits
of bipartisanship and as jen
saki saki now i know as jen saki
said many times now bipartisanship
doesn't mean
that you unite republicans and democrats
into one party democrats say 1.9
trillion
and it includes the uh pre
it includes the payments that we've
outlined before in terms of payments to
individuals
payments for children business stimulus
enhanced unemployment
money for vaccine all these different
things republicans want something so
dramatically different that there's
really no way to negotiate to anything
that would make sense
the american people are overwhelmingly
on the side of joe biden and democrats
not everybody
but significant support for the 1.9
trillion dollar package so it's just
time to pass it and
this would be a major accomplishment
for joe biden my expectation would be
that as high as joe biden's approval
rating is right now
and it's the highest initial job
approval of any president since bill
clinton in 1993 over 28 years
right now this is the highest initial
approval rating of any president dating
back 28 years
i think it goes higher if joe biden is
able to get this done in the next 10
days
and if not it will start to be a drag on
him politically
politics aside we need to do it for the
economy we need to do it for people
and i remain cautiously optimistic
that in the next seven to ten days there
will be progress
we'll see what is said about it at this
week's press briefings with jensaki
which of course we'll be covering on
youtube twitch and
facebook